how do we know if we're playing it too
safe in our career oh my gosh I love
that question so much
um I think it's a if we can slow down
long enough to listen to our bodies we
can feel it we can feel it in our bones
we can feel it in our our belly where
there's a sense of
dissonance and so um going back to this
idea of values and so if you're playing
it safe in your career I'm gonna say
just by the nature of that question that
the value underlying that is like let me
take some risks let me really meet my
potential let me like pursue possibility
and so if you're not doing that you're
probably going to if you can slow down
just like feel it in your body in some
form like maybe your gut is like a
little bit clenched or your neck is a
little bit tight or your jaw is like you
know really hanging on and so then
leaning into curiosity of like okay
what's happening in my body where is
that coming from and
so there's definitely a point in my
career where I was totally playing it
safe and if I could have slowed down
long enough I think I would have start
started to understand some like the
aches that I was feeling in my body and
I think I could have connected the
dots um another way I think to know if
you're playing it too safe in your
career is um is if you're not um if
you're not getting those results if
you're not feeling successful if you're
not feeling
fulfilled that you may be on someone
else's treadmill and not your
own because you believe that that other
treadmill is going
to validate you in some way but you're
not actually aligned with your values
and your
purpose do you think there's a
possibility of playing it too too safe
especially like the entertainment
industry or even Venture Capital Silicon
Valley there's like these big swings you
know and oh go big or go home and you
know it's almost rewarded yeah that's
another really really great question
because I think there's an important
distinction between playing it too safe
from a place of
fear versus being patient and
strategic and so I think you really have
to look at and feel
into is it fear-based or am I honoring a
value and listening to my
intuition and so I'm just going to give
another example where I feel like I've
said yes to career opportunities out of
fear and and I think feeling like okay
I'm playing it safe I'm going too slow I
want things to move along more
quickly and where if I would have slowed
down enough to identify okay what values
am I honoring and saying yes to this
opportunity how is this honoring my
purpose how does it fit into the bigger
overall strategy of how I want my life
to look like I think I I probably would
have made some different
choices you know it it seems to be a
major theme of everything I hear from
you is just really like listening to
within you think that's possible is that
possible in a fast-paced
you know town like Los Angeles in the
entertainment industry where there's
other people that they're just going to
say yes they're not going to listen to
anything is that are we are we being
realistic can we really kind of own and
listen and feel what's in our body in
this
industry not only do I think it's
possible I think it's absolutely
critical in order to be able to have
long-term success and Longevity and
fulfillment absolutely it's we're in
such a interesting moment in time right
now where there's so much contraction in
the entertainment
industry and business models have been
disrupted and we haven't figured out how
to put those pieces together again and
it's not even going back to something
it's like it's carving out something new
so there's a real kind of um Pioneer
Energy to what's happening and so the
only way to be able to navigate that is
to go Inward and to listen and to have
quiet time because um there's a a time
to fail quickly and there's a time to
listen deeply I think right now is a
time to be listening deeply not sure if
you saw the Ted talk with Dolph lungren
oh I did oh well I highly recommend it
and he talked about having all the
success but that he realized inside
there was all these things that he
hadn't been listening to cuz he was so
busy becoming and doing all these things
and that he was able to finally stop and
and realize what different things that
had happened to him but for so long he
was just going going going and I think
did you talk about this as well and just
how we sometimes we have to kind of
swallow any feelings because we we can't
show up on the job of course or or on
set u broken or or depressed you know we
have to maintain yeah absolutely it's I
have two thoughts on that is is one is
that I mean once you get the
opportunity and you you get the job
whatever that might
be there's there's so much pressure
because there is so much competition of
like oh I've got my opportunity I better
not screw this up and there are people
who are counting on me and so like if
I'm not prepared or I make a mistake or
I make a failure a I'm going to screw up
my life in my career but that also has
impact on everybody else so yeah it like
it it requires a level of surpressing
negating uh repressing feelings but in
the big picture that doesn't really help
it may help in the day but it doesn't
help in the overall because it's
creating so much stress and tension and
anxiety and then that starts to filter
into not just your own work but also the
work because entertainment is
collaborative
and so it starts to have an have an
impact for
sure and I I'd love to say one other
thing on this point which is and this
comes from again this this perspective
of being a people pleaser and a
perfectionist which I feel like a lot of
people in the entertainment industry
really share that and it creates a
spiral so for me where the way that I
can be a people pleaser is if I'm
engaged with people and there's a task
and it's like great I've got a task I
can do it and I can do it really well
and I can get an adag girl and so but
it's like eating cotton candy and so
great I got the adag girl but now I need
another one because it's it doesn't
actually have any real nutritional value
so it just gives me like this
instantaneous high but there's no real
sustainability or Foundation to that so
then I need another task and another
task and another task so when you talk
about Del lungren um Ted Talk I really
get that because he had to keep showing
up and he kept saying yes that he could
get his adab boy and and the pressure of
that because if he screws up then he's
not going to get another opportunity and
it creates this horrific spiral that
again just is not sustainable it really
has huge impact personally
professionally and within our
communities you know that's a great
thought in terms of yeah people in any
type of entertainment being people
Pleasers and that's kind of what you're
doing you're performing and okay can you
dance faster okay great that's trying we
want to please the audience
any type of content creator so that's
yeah that's fascinating yeah and it's
like I feel like it shows up on every
level whether you're below the line
above the line whether you're an
executive or you know like whatever it
is it just like it shows
up